so hi everyone and thank you very much
for attending my talk I'll be talking
about fashion product retrieval
multimodal input and again so there's a
lot of buzzwords and let's go for it
first of all a couple of words about me
so I'm Ivana I work at two blokes which
is a software house based in Poland
Europe I'm also doing my PhD in computer
science and machine learning I have some
background in mathematics and in my free
time I working as a concert photographer
so actually those two things concert
photography and mathematics led me to my
passion for computer vision and teaching
computers how to understand images and
what's in them so during my job at two
books I've had a chance to help build a
lot of amazing products most of them
from here from Silicon Valley so I've
helped develop like a passenger counting
system a motion recognition system for
autonomous taxi company from California
also Smart Oven company smart tire
company a lot of smart things so yeah
and today I'll be talking about products
retrieval so why do we need that and as
a consumer why are we interested in
products for evil a typical use case
would be one it's actually quite yeah
quite happened to me a lot as well
you're just walking in the street or
riding a subway and you see somebody
wearing an item you like it might be bag
shoes anything else so you could just
approach that person and ask hey buddy I
like your shoes where did you buy them
but that's a bit awkward for me what is
not awkward is just not a picture of a
stranger and search it's in the Internet
yeah all right so I guess we can just
use Google Image Search and I think is
if you search for similar images you
might find other images of people
wearing shoes and those definitely are
visually similar Am I
but they're not what we were looking for
so what comes next is actually a lot of
huge companies started doing visual
search on a lot better way and one of
the pioneers was Pinterest they
published a couple of very interesting
papers about their methods and they also
implemented this solution in their app
and website so it can actually take a
product that you like and search for
visually similar ones and works really
well also more retailers online shops
everybody started using this visual
search so a sauce zalando some Chinese
ones such as Alibaba or Aliexpress
everybody starts using that and adding
as a feature in their apps so this is
actually very good for consumer because
you can just snap a picture find similar
items and you're good and why is it
gaining so much for polarity one thing
is it's very easy so actually if you
don't even need to have label data for
the most simple visual search algorithm
you don't even need to train a model you
don't even need a GPU to have like the
simplest visual search what do you need
is actually just a bunch of images your
database that you already should have
and you get a pre train network
preferably on image net it might be any
architecture ResNet ji inception and you
just feed all your images for this pre
train network you remove the last layer
which has probabilities for image net
classes that you don't really care about
and now this second to last layer is
actually your vector representation or
an embedding and multi-dimensional space
that you can use as an index to search
for other vectors in the same
multi-dimensional space so you choose a
distance metric l1 l2 find the closest
vectors and you have the closest
visually similar images so this works
very well because networks retain on
image net already named or already
learned such features as colors shapes
and these are actually the features that
we are looking for in visuals
but going forward if you actually have
some data and you want to train an even
better model what you can do is you can
teach Siam its network so to train a
Siamese Network you would need to have
some positive pairs so in this case you
would have pictures of the same product
but of different angles different
situations it might be a picture of
white background catalog photo and also
everyone where somebody is just wearing
the product in real life so then you
feed those two images for some CNN
architecture
it also doesn't matter so much it might
be pre trained or not it depends on the
amounts of data that you have and in the
end you calculate the contrast of loss
so in the case of the pictures of
similar product positive pair you want
this distance to be smaller than a
predefined margin and in the case of
negative pair you want this distance to
be larger than a predefined margin and
this is also a fine tuning parameter
that you have to play with to find the
best values also worth mentioning that
those pairs the negative person
specially don't have to be too hard and
too easy if you gave it a negative pair
of like shoe in the back it might be too
easy for model 2 it would learn it
instantly but if you give it too hard
pairs that are almost similar but these
are of different products just very
similar it might be difficult to
converge so that's also art and itself
getting those pairs kind of similar
approach is what triplet networks here
you don't have pairs you have triplets
so we start with an anchor image and you
get a positive and a negative the
difference here is that you don't say
anything about the distances whether
they should be smaller or larger than
the margin you just say that the
distance between anchor and positive has
to be smaller than the distance between
anchor and negative one and what happens
during training is that in the
multi-dimensional embedding space those
those embeddings of an anchor and
positive actually get closer together
the one of a negative one gets further
and during inference again you just
calculate the distances find the closest
vectors and this is this is your result
so you might take any picture which is
not present in data set run it for the
network calculated simulating and find
the closest one from the database now
this is all for the visual search but
sometimes image is not enough sometimes
you don't have a perfect image you have
image of shoes but you want them in
different color or something in
different shape and this is actually
where multi modal search comes into the
picture because multi model in this case
would mean that our input query is not
just visual signal it's also a text
signal so there are two typical user
case scenarios that you would want to do
that and one is one is a particular when
you have an image which is not perfect
so you might want these shoes in black
or in lever or anything else or you
might have a different use case and this
is the case where you can't even have an
image which describes the thing
correctly so you might have an image of
sneakers that look comfortable and look
cheap but who knows they're comfortable
and cheap so these are some of the
features that are just not translatable
to images and we want them to be defined
in natural language we don't want to be
restricted by any predefined features or
tags or classes anything like that so to
do that actually me and my colleagues
did some research at two books and we've
developed a deep style Network which
tackled just this problem of multimodal
search given some image and text input
and the first network that we've develop
a couple years ago already it was was
this one where we used classification as
an auxilary task so we learned
multimodal descriptors by doing regular
classification just an input was image
and text we also used
pre-trained image and text encoders so
for image encoder you can use ResNet
training on image net or inception net
it doesn't really matter that much it
just changes the accuracy by a couple of
percent and for text you can use word to
fake clove or any other text encoding
method on top of that a couple of fully
collected layers that were actually
trained and in the end where we have the
softmax it's not an actual multimodal
descripton is actually is before the
second to last layer which is the image
and text descriptor that we are using
for search going forward we improved
this method even more by adding a semi
component so right now having this
information the data set that some of
the products are similar or maybe
they're of similar style or maybe they
fit together quite well we're able to
train in even better network for
multimodal embeddings and in this case
we train on pairs of products but each
of those pairs of products is is an
image and text itself so it has two
branches already and the weights are
shared between two deep style networks
and the network is optimized with free
losses so we have one loss for we have
contrastive loss which says whether
those two products represented by image
and text should be close together or
further together in the embedding space
and for each of them we also have a
classification loss typical one so by
training this we were actually we were
able to improve over some baselines
state of the art at the time and to get
multimodal retrieval that represents
both image features and text features
given an some random text now the
problem with the research is that
sometimes you you train a great model
you have perfect accuracy you improve
over baselines then you implemented the
production and what happens users start
using that
they are not happy they don't like that
so in this example let's imagine we have
a user upload sneakers picture and he
gets some black shoes and result we
would say well it's it's still shoes
right the results are not that not that
trash but the user doesn't get the the
shoes he's looking for so he doesn't
care if it's sneakers or bags or shirts
or whatever he just did not find those
sneakers he was looking for so the
problem is that by just seeing those
results we don't really know what went
wrong it might be the model it might be
the architecture but in the given
database
perhaps there are just no colorful
sneakers
maybe that's the closest that the model
was able to get by finding other shoes
there were just no similar ones so
especially in the terms of multimodal
search it's very different it's very
important to have this component of
interpretability and being able to say
what we are looking for and what is user
being given so this is where this our
idea comes into life is that we want to
introduce this interpreter
it's interpretable element to our most
model search and we're tackling this
with generative models so given an image
and text query we want to create a
synthetic image that actually represents
both image and text and then use it in a
regular visual search so here come the
guns just a quick question how many of
you here have trained gasps okay how
many of you know what guns are okay
that's better
so you guys are not well they are fun to
train but there's a lot of problems
while training gasps stability moat
collapse so this is really fun but in a
bad way as well and the problem with the
regular guess is that you cannot
influence the images that are generated
in any way
so you get some synthetic cats but you
cannot just say that you want a cat with
blue eyes and vanilla conversion you
just give some random noise and you get
a cute cat picture in return now there
is a lot of improvements over vanilla
gas very popular one is a conditional
again where you can conditioner by label
so if in your data you have some labels
you're able to feed those labels both to
the generator and to the discriminator
so by generating images you feed some
noise on one hand but also you're
feeding the label first the generator
doesn't know anything about the labels
so it just takes it but then
discriminator is given real image with
label and generated image if good label
so even if generator was able to create
some good-looking images but they are
not corresponding to labels well then
the discriminator wouldn't be fooled so
this is why we are able to actually
condition on this label and we are for
example here able to generate clothing
images that are conditioned on color
label going so there there is for
example info again and here what's
interesting you can you can even input
not only a categorical variable but you
can give continuous variable C which
doesn't actually even need to be
predefined I just learned by model
during training it captures some
characteristics of the data so in this
case it's actually trained on Salib data
set and it learns it learns to associate
values of these continuous variable with
posts or rotation and now going forward
there are some interesting models that
actually allow you to generate images
from text attention gun is especially
cool because the authors of this method
use attentional models and this way they
are able to create images with some
contacts
in the case of birds data set when you
have text queries such as a red bird
with blue wings you don't want this blue
wings text part to influence all of your
image just certain parts of that so it
comes it comes naturally and the authors
are getting some promising results on
the birds data set when we tried to
apply this approach to clothing later
set it appeared that some general
concepts look it look quite good and are
quite promising so in this case we are
giving it a text query bright long red
party dress and what we see is bright
long red party dress so it's kind of
cool and also they give us some
attention maps that show which words
which words trigger which attention maps
unfortunately they are not very fine
great they don't give a lot of details
but some words such as bright and red in
this case we are seeing that they are
indeed influencing those parts of the
image that they should be influencing
now from the same authors there is
another very interesting models tagging
and this one is actually a two-stage
generative model which first from the
text query creates a low resolution
image and then uses that to create a
higher resolution one also conditioned
by the same text query and now it the
problem with this approach is that in
the second stage it only changes image
and some parts that are responsible for
creating higher resolution image so if
in first stage you created blue dress
you wouldn't be able to change it in the
second stage to something else so this
comes into the question okay but how do
we make gas with multimodal input we
don't only want to have textual input
per label input we want to have it all
so we didn't find any appropriate
research on the subject so we started
with our own
it's a very so it's still
work-in-progress so and we are going to
publish it soon and we have a don't have
a catchy name for that and research here
is supposedly to have a very catchy name
for that so right now I'm just calling
it triplet again but the idea here is to
leverage on the information about the
similarity so for some time we had ideas
that we weren't able to experiment with
because there wasn't good data for that
and without the data you're just you're
just nothing so we were very happy when
fashion IQ dataset got released because
they have exactly the data what we need
because just having images and text is
not enough and we need those relative
captions we need data in the form of
image plus text equals another image and
by having this relative captions which
correspond to differences between images
we are able to do just that give an
image plus text we receive a second
image and our idea is to incorporate gas
with triplet loss by having this target
image that corresponds to our actual
ground truth so first image and texts
are fed from some pre trained image
encoders as usual and then instead of
noise we feed this this Commodus
concatenated image and text features to
generator to create some artificially
looking image now the generator would
learn to fool the discriminator by
giving us some clothing images which is
not yet good enough we are so adding the
triplet loss so that the distances
between the generated image and the
actual ground truth image is smaller
than the distance to some other random
image by adding this loss to the
generator back during back prop the
generator is able to create images that
correspond well to the input image and
input caption so essentially what we are
able to do this
is by having imagine the left which is
in some stripes and user query is in
wide and has a pocket we generate the
third image that is then later used for
general visual search and we are able to
return at the closest results and what
is better with this approach than just
using text to image is that we are able
to capture app information present in
the image itself so it's not yet
changing some parts of the image which
also quite an interesting idea that we
are going to experiment with its
generating image from scratch but by
having this encode their information and
the generator were able to capture some
important information such as color such
as a person if it's wearing a clothes or
is it just a clothes on white background
some general shapes or body shapes etc
so this already gives us some
interesting results and we are also
working on improving this wet method
even further and this would be it thank
you very much for your attention
I would be very happy to answer any
questions hi I'm great doc thank you
have you considered the use case where
somebody needs to revamp their wardrobe
so whatever styles they're looking for
are exactly or to a certain degree
unlike what they currently have okay so
you mean in the case of matching styles
but not the exact items so let's say
somebody's entire wardrobe is in blue
green and red they don't want any of
those anymore okay that's a different
use case cuz then then you would have
actually I'd you would want items that
in the embedding space are not so close
but not so far so I mean if you have a
good embedding space that perhaps would
be possible but we have
played with that okay first of all
thanks for the presentation that was
awesome and see just curious like what
are your plans with this are you selling
it yeah you know the fashion industry
and picking up clients or is there some
other plan and just curious how how
that's been so far yeah sure so right
now it's in the research phase but it's
research that I'm doing at to looks and
at our company we're actually doing a
lot of research before we go to clients
and what we found is that a lot of
companies then go to us because they are
interested in doing there's that and
yeah we've had some some companies
actually asked about those methods
because I feel that in fashion industry
there is this FOMO right now that there
is a lot of interesting stuff that you
can do especially if you have like vast
databases
everybody's doing visual search so it's
kind of already passe but there is a lot
of more interesting stuff like what
multimodal search like outfit
compatibility and there is a lot of
leverage so yeah we're hoping to apply
that we've already had some smaller
projects on using the multimodal search
on client site but yeah I'm hoping to
see that implemented even more so great
talk
where do you see the future or the
potential of these kinds of services in
the next five to ten years well so I
think that perhaps it would be
ever-present just everywhere and easier
to use definitely because the the tool
that Pinterest has is quite cool but the
most like the most of other tools that
I've like tried on they're not so good
yet you just download the app it looks
cool and then it's not quite what you
want so I think that to be used on a
large scale there is still some room for
improvement and I hope that in like next
five years
as gap would be would be overcome and it
would be so much easier to use and yeah
for present okay so there are no
questions then thank you again very much
and yeah have a nice one
[Applause]